pourquoi dit-on être pleins aux as et
c'est une question de xxl ou beck's pour
certains les origines de cette
expression remonterait à la rome antique
où les as étaient des petites pièces de
cuivre qui servaient de monnaie avoir
plein d'asti ni fiez donc être riche
exactement comme êtres pleins aux as
aujourd'hui mais le fait que
l'expression ne soit utilisé que depuis
le début du 20e siècle semble plutôt
donné raison à une seconde explication
selon laquelle elle nous viendrait du
poker dans ce jeu de quart devenu très
populaire aux états unis au 19e siècle
lass est en effet une carte maîtresse à
voir dans son jeu un carré d'as ou un
full aux as et presque toujours synonyme
de victoire et peut donc permettre de
gagner pas mal d'argent l'expression
serait donc tout simplement la
traduction en français de full aux as
plein aux as